Aqueles pesadelos que te acordam no meio
da noite, pois é, eles podem estar te
avisando algo muito mais sério sobre o
seu cérebro. Olha só, um estudo novo
descobriu que ter pesadelos toda semana
na meia idade aumenta em quatro vezes a
chance de desenvolver problemas
cognitivos nos próximos anos. E nos
idosos, a chance de demência dobra. Veja
bem, não é qualquer sonho ruim
esporádico, não. Estamos falando de
pesadelos frequentes toda semana. O
interessante é que isso acontece mais
nos homens. A teoria que esses pesadelus
podem ser um dos primeiros sinais de que
algo não vai bem no cérebro, aparecendo
anos antes de outros sintomas. É como se
fosse um alarme precoce que nosso
organismo dispara durante o sono. Então,
se você ou alguém próximo tem pesadelos
constantes, vale a pena ficar atento e
investigar. Afinal, quanto antes a gente
identifica, melhor consegue agir.